>> All right. So let's take a look at how this falls out. The drawSprite
function is given a string representing the name of the loose asset that we'd
like to draw. In order to draw it on the screen, the first thing we have to do
is iterate through all of the sprite sheets that have already been loaded, and
determine whether or not this sprite name exists on that sprite sheet. Now, to
make this a little bit easier, we've actually abstracted out and created a new
GetStats object on our spreadsheet. The getStats function will effectively take
in a name, and walk through all of the sprites for the sheet to determine
whether of not this sprite with that name exists on this sheet. If so, it will
go ahead and return the sprite information, if not, will return no. Passing it,
the sprite information from the sheet. The sheet itself as well as the position
x and position y, passing it through. Now drawSpriteInternal is where all the
magic happens. First we start at the top of it by defining a few sanity checks
to make sure that someone else in the code base isn't calling this function with
improper data. Next what we do is actually create a nice little variable that
holds off the center x and center y translation value that we defined when we
were loading our asset. Next we go to our version of draw image that has all the
fancy perameters. From here, we define the source x, y, width and height values
passed to us directly from the sprite object that was defined from our json
atlas definition. The next 2 values is the, where we want to draw this sprite to
on the destination canvas. And that's going to equal to the position x that
we've been given by the calling function, as well as half x and half y. So that
we can actually put the center of the Sprite, at the location that we're
interested in drawing in, as opposed to the top-left corner. And, as we said
before, the destination width and height should be equal to our source width and
height in the sprite atlas.